[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos a 5 minutos con
según un reporte de la ong world vision
el matrimonio infantil se ha duplicado
durante la pandemia de kobe 19 en
américa latina y el caribe 110 millones
de niñas se casarán contra su voluntad
en esta década nos acompañan a michelle
mitchell bernard directora regional de
comunicaciones de world vision michelle
bienvenida a américa latina y el caribe
es la única región del mundo en la que
estas cifras no han bajado en 10 años y
ahora con la pandemia la situación
tiende a empeorar porque no se logra
superar esta violación de los derechos
de las niñas y cómo se relaciona con la
pobreza
claro muy buenos días juan irme a los
días a todas de la audiencia desde aquí
de san jose costa rica
en efecto el matrimonio infantil ha
mostrado una tendencia creciente en el
último año the world visión ha detectado
que se han duplicado los reportes de
matrimonio infantil particularmente lo
que denominamos contextos frágiles
aquellos lugares en donde las
necesidades económicas mínimas ni
siquiera son satisfechas y que por
supuesto tienen adicionalmente en
complicaciones como lo pueden ser los
conflictos sociales estamos hablando de
12 millones de niñas que cada año entran
en esta categoría y por qué sucede esto
juan cuál es la relación que tiene con
la pobreza estamos hablando que en el
marco de una pandemia que es donde hemos
visto que ha aumentado de manera
significativa el número de los
matrimonios infantiles muchas familias
no encuentran los medios para efectos de
poder satisfacer las necesidades
materiales básicas me refiero
alimentación en pagar los servicios el
arriendo lugar a donde la gente vive
entonces es una solución que algunos han
encontrado
desde antes incluso la encontraban era
dar a las niñas entregar a sus niñas en
matrimonio una forma de tener una boca
menos que alimentar por supuesto que es
una forma perversa porque sabemos que
despoja a las niñas de sus derechos
básicos uno por ejemplo es el hecho de
que es introducir en una relación de
abuso con un hombre que es mayor que
ella
estamos hablando de niñas tan pequeñas
de 9 10 años hasta adolescentes y por
supuesto las encadenadas en un proceso
de dependencia económica en donde lo que
sucede es que ellas se vuelven ahora sí
personas pobres las condenas a la
pobreza profesión estima que 4 millones
de niñas adicionales podrían casarse
debido a la pandemia de cara al 2022 a
nivel global hay un componente que
influye y es el embarazo adolescente
adolescente entre otras cosas por abuso
de oportunidades necesitan las mujeres
para que esto no pase más
educación educación y más educación y
aquí por supuesto que requerimos del
compromiso de toda la sociedad estamos
hablando que nuestra organización world
vision está elevando una petición global
a todos los gobiernos para que hagan
cumplir la legislación que impide el
matrimonio infantil y que tiene como
consecuencia el embarazo adolescente que
dicho sea de paso américa latina tiene
la segunda tasa más alta de américa
latina- en un contexto tan difícil en
donde la mayor parte de los recursos
públicos son destinados a la prevención
y mitigación de la pandemia
sabemos que entonces queda poco para
efectos de poder prevenir el matrimonio
infantil y por supuesto que el embarazo
adolescente pero nuevamente a quien
llamamos a los gobiernos hacer cumplir
la edad mínima para el matrimonio
infantil y además el poder proveer los
mecanismos de educación y empoderamiento
en cuanto a derechos sexuales y
reproductivos que las niñas y las
adolescentes requieren apropiados a su
edad de tal manera que no resulten
embarazadas en el momento que ya
resultan embarazadas
el riesgo en el espacio lo comentaba
antes 12 millones de niñas contraen
matrimonio antes de los 18 años como
entender que esto siga pasando en pleno
siglo 21 nos quedaba poco menos de un
minuto o michel como les digo nuevamente
todo ser humano y las niñas no están
exentas de poder de disfrutar plenamente
de sus derechos y además de poder
cumplir todos sus objetivos desde web
visión queremos llamarle a usted a que
por favor vaya a nuestras páginas
globales w y punto o hereje
repito w punto hereje y firme a la
petición que está allí que vamos a
elevar a los gobiernos a la sociedad
civil para que usted levante la voz y
denuncie esto que está sucediendo en
pleno siglo 21 es inaceptable queremos
que nuestras niñas alcancen su pleno
potencial y eso solamente lo lograremos
asegurando su acceso a la educación la
protección a través de los sistemas de
protección social que existen en los
países y por supuesto el compromiso a
los padres de familia y de la comunidad
para impedir que esto suceda
michelle verdad muchísimas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros y gracias
también a ustedes por estar en france 24
gente porque la información continua
[Música]